(whimsical guitar music)
- I'm the youngest
certified integrative nutrition
health coach in the country
and the world, as far as I know,
but I usually don't say that part.
Hi, my name is Haile Thomas.
I'm 17 years old, a vegan health activist,
the CEO of The HAPPY
Organization, and a total foodie.
The healthy eating aspect
really came out of my dad,
who was diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
when I was about eight
and that's when we really
just started experimenting
with healthy foods
and decided to ditch the medication.
And in a few years, we were actually able
to completely reverse his condition,
and so that, to me,
proved the power of food,
but also the potential in healthy foods,
and eventually becoming vegan.
The inspiration behind
the sweet potato pizza
that I'm making today really
came from just being creative
and kind of playing around.
I absolutely love sweet potatoes.
They're one of my favorites
foods besides avocados,
and so I really wanted to find
a way to get that sweetness,
but that heartiness.
Essentially just being able
to take a core group of ingredients
and kind of swap it out, and mix it up,
and add different sauces,
and add different greens,
and proteins, and things like
that is really fun for me
and I enjoy kind of playing
with those combinations.
That's kind of how this pizza was born.
My advocacy really started
when I was about 10
and saw this evidence of
my dad just getting better
and our family learning so much
from not only one perspective
of food and exercise,
but also all the other
components of just life
that contribute to health and wellbeing.
That was really eye-opening for me
and definitely helped me
integrate those aspects
into our nonprofit programs
and just in everyday life for me as well.
Oh, my gosh, I love Michelle Obama.
She is amazing and I'm so incredibly lucky
to have met her six or seven times.
I'm just always so
constantly inspired by her
and everything that she does
and everything that she represents.
Her telling me to just keep on going
and continue to stay strong in everything
that I'm trying to share
because the world really
does need to hear it
and that has fueled me literally
for the past six years,
so I am so proud to be a black girl
in Gen Z representing food and wellness.
It's so important for us to
embrace health and wellbeing
in order for us to all fuel
our dreams and passions,
and so I'm grateful to be in this space
and grateful to share this message.